shakes and then I came out here I was
turned seven
and then um
you know that's where some of that
happened that sex was part of my sister
what what tell me about what happened to
you
when you were born you were born born
where I was born in Alabama
yeah what part I bought I believe it
would be mobile
so you know uh it got pressured on a
birth certificate but I believe in
mobile I'm not really sure but on on a
birth certificate is uh say Pritchard
which is next to next door to it what
was your family like
well my family is like
um you know uh dysfunctional you know I
know that for certain but uh growing up
you know we just regular family you know
the fighting and and stuff like that
single parent home
and uh you know and so we carried on as
you know my sister basically raised this
the one that I'm talking about that you
know this incest stuff happened with and
uh what happened
well I mean I screwed my sister and my
brother my brother this morning too been
screwing it for a long time and uh
because he's older than me
huh when did that start
um I don't know when they actually
started but when I came out here I was
seven and so it started I seen them do
that to her
you know during that time and then I'm
sure it carried on uh you know a a
longer with him and her with him and her
I mean you were seven how old was your
your sister
my sister had to be in probably about 15
or 16 some she about about six or seven
years older than I am
and uh and then my brother he like I
think four and a half years older than
me the one I'm talking about
yeah so you put it you do the math on
that
you know no I think probably about 60
years something like that
yeah I know so what other questions you
would ask me
no it's it's just what was the Dynamics
in the family that that was going on
your mom was working her mom's work my
mom's single parent home my mother
worked most of the time working a couple
jobs and done so my sister was left to
raises you know the one that just
happened with and I got another older
sister but she wasn't living with us at
the time and uh so the one that's under
her
you know kind of rages and and so we was
together all the time and she pretty
much was the mom you know because my
mother was gone and when she come in uh
yeah a fairly common thing that was
going on yeah I believe so in the South
because I mean it's a lot most you know
the families back there got 13 14 kids
and so we all slept in the same bed you
know because we poor I slept with my
sisters I got another little sister
and uh we slept together and so of
course you know we were close in that
capacity and so it wouldn't be nothing
to you know turn over and you know uh
you know rub my sister or you know get
you know rexiness and perhaps you know
and do something to her you know and uh
and before you know it you know we uh
you know uh doing something we probably
seen on TV or or in the magazine or
whatever you know curiosity it would
happen and uh and so you know that
happens and then um when we came out
here uh you know we kind of like pulled
a train on my sister and then I stopped
because my other brother did it too he's
older than me he had a little older than
me my brother Tim he's a little older
than me and uh and so I realized
something was wrong I did it you know
briefly and uh and so I stopped
and uh but I'm sure it carried on with
my my older brother this one that's
older than the one that's older than me
right next to me and then my brother
called is uh he's uh he's about six
years older than me this was more than
one of your sisters or just one of them
just one just the one because she's the
one that's been taking care of us you
know like a like a mother you know
cooking and taking us where we needed it
wasn't necessarily she was being forced
into it of course not of course not no
and we never talked about it even to
this day but and I don't think they
realize that I uh remember all this
stuff you know and because of course we
never talked about it but now I know for
a fact that uh you know they they've
been together a lot my brother and my
sister that you know they're trying to
continue because he's been screwing it
for a while you know and uh so
and so
and I think this is what causes me to
you know get in trouble and stay in
trouble all this time you know been like
suppressing it and then prior to that I
told you that uh I had sex with uh my
brother his friends and all that stuff
when he was back in Alabama and then I'd
realized something was wrong you know at
that time too you know and then I
stopped you know but it happened and I
don't really really know how many times
I think it probably happened about a
couple times before I realized that uh
you know this is not normal
and uh and I didn't Resort back to it
but I don't know if you realize I
remember all that do you think it
impacts you today is it at all do you
think it impacts your life as an adult
of course for sure I'm sure it does it
has you know because uh
uh we don't talk about that it's been
suppressed and that you know it was a
form of abuse
you know from an older older sibling and
uh and his friends or whatever I don't
think if they realized you know what
they were doing or you know they
probably was carrying on what they'd
seen somebody else do you know back in
that time you know it's a lot of
a lot of that going on in in the South
you know it probably is probably
elsewhere too because I ran into a guy
you know uh you know that was doing the
same thing and he was so glad that I was
able to share that wedding because he
had been holding that inside himself and
then I told him about the book The VC
Andrews book about the uh Flowers in the
Attic and that's a book that explains
you know how this occurs and uh that you
know that God uh your eyes washed bread
and then these two siblings they they
married each other and had kids and
continued that life you know because
they were stuck with each other because
their mother was out doing what she does
and she kind of like put them on the
Shelf kind of like try to hide them and
the grandmother didn't like him and
stuff like that and so they had to learn
how to uh take care of each other and so
that's what they did and I don't know if
uh that book I know helped me
but at the same time
yeah I think it's more rice bread than
we realized people are just not talking
about it yeah we just we don't you know
we I haven't talked to my brothers and
sisters about this ever this first time
matter of fact
I shared it with one another guy before
and because I wouldn't talk about it of
course I wouldn't talk about now I don't
feel nothing to talk about it because I
think it should be told and it's
something I want to get out because it
helps me you know grow and get out of
the things probably that I'm having you
know because it's related I believe
something that's going on in your adult
life now come again tell me tell me how
you're oh right now you know I'm just
trying to I just got out of prison
um November I got out of prison November
for some robberies and stuff but I've
been in and out of jail over half of my
life and uh due to drug addiction and uh
I got myself off the methadone I'm on up
and so I've been kind of like you know
messing around with a fitting all a
little bit trying to wean myself off and
I got a lightweight Jones now for that
but uh I've been messing with drugs and
stuff like that but I'm finna clean up
and all that now I'm trying to do the
best I can with what I have and uh and
be strong you know because now I'm free
you know I don't have to worry about you
know going back to prison or doing other
things you know because I I have some
marketable skills and all I need is just
a little assistance you know to put what
I was telling you about earlier in in
effect and uh how old are you now how
old am I I'm 59 59. yeah and so I've
been written over half of my life
I did 37 years
I've been on the streets prior to this
uh I did five five years and six months
this November I just got out but prior
to that I did 20
straight
and uh but I haven't been on the street
in 15 months what was the 20 straight
for what was it said again the 20 years
you did what was that for uh for
possession uh drug possession over there
at Torrance they gave him three strikes
and had three strikes 25 to life
and that's what I was telling you about
that's one of the cases I got overturned
and you've been homeless since you've
gone up I just got out on another case
in November that was I did five and a
half on that one it's not related to
that one but I went in there for some
robbers then bank robberies and went in
there for that and uh I was able to use
that
judgment that I got against the state
and to help get out on this one because
they was trying to strike me out again
and uh so you get institutionalized
do I believe I'm instantly I think so
because uh you know it's not normal
behavior you can't keep going doing the
same thing getting the same results and
uh and you know and and so it has to be
something wrong and then that's why I
believe it's something mental
to you know we we find out now that uh
you know mental you know smoking in the
home you know depending smoke in the
home or I didn't talk to the kids or
whatever and a verbal Bruce you know
would that happen to me a lot you know
because I was a mess up I I was a sheep
of black sheep of the family so to speak
you know stayed in trouble and so you
know of course my mother lashed out she
probably didn't mean to but of course
that I believe that it affected me I
know it did was your dad in the picture
huh was your dad in your life I don't
know nothing about my father I never I
don't know nothing about him I'd never
seen a picture of him you know his name
or nothing and every time I would ask
about it uh of course she would tell me
you know yeah I'm your I'm your daddy
and then I kept pressing it one time and
uh
she finally told me he was dead so I
don't really believe it but that was a
way to you know set me up you know from
asking about it but no I don't know
nothing about my father
you know and most of us don't uh even my
older sisters you know
the only one one of my siblings do some
about his father no I take that back my
older brother he knew about his father
and then the one I'm talking about that
the incest that happened with he he knew
his he know of his father
and uh and so some of the rest of us
most of you most of the kids in your
family had different fathers yeah I
believe so yeah
yeah it's uh all together there's ten of
us and uh so now it's uh
I got I lost one two
I lost two of two of my brothers already
and so it's only uh it's uh
me and my brother saw us three it's
three of us left and then I got my three
sisters so let's make six then I got
another brother that's uh that uh didn't
live with us that makes seven he's in
Detroit of the ten kids how many how
many have the same father
um I think two that'd be my younger
brother and my my younger sister and
everyone else has a different father
in the red I believe so yeah I'm not
sure because we don't know I don't I
don't know who the father of you know
and then when I was young I seen some
I've seen some uh guys around that used
to come over early you know in in the
household when we was in the projects uh
back in Alabama I used to see him come
over I didn't know who they were or
nothing like that but I remember seeing
them you know as a kid early in the
morning drinking coffee and stuff like
that perhaps before they went to work
you know so it could be the father some
I don't know
but um I don't know the name but uh my
father and they they don't eat it you
know
do you feel like you're you're about
your your time in prison
are because of the way your childhood
was
I believe I believe that I have
something to do with it I'm under
impression that like I say about 80 or
90 percent of the people that is on
drugs you know have an underlying
condition that causes them to use drugs
you know that's something that we don't
address either you know all we see is
person on drugs and you don't care how
they got there but you know it's
something underlining that makes them do
that and they're trying to get a
temporary fix perhaps and then of course
you get hooked or whatever and then and
the cycle keep going on but yeah it's
definitely something none of there what
do you go through emotionally in your oh
mostly wow man I went through a lot I
cry a lot and man I cry on a dime you
know because uh you know I really didn't
get a chance to you know uh say much to
my mother because we never talked and
you know I love my mother and I never
got a chance to really you know sure
that uh
you know I understand and that uh
because of course I've been in prison
you know over half my life I was in
prison when she when she passed you know
so uh it's kind of raw subject and you
know it's easy for me to have you know
emotionally yeah I've gone through a lot
you know even in the last few weeks you
know because I got reacquainted with
some of my my brothers and sisters
because I haven't talked to them in a
long time on my own accord and then they
found me you know down here down here
downtown here they found me and um so I
reacquainted with them and then some of
the stuff they my sister was telling me
and my nephew is like overwhelming you
know and so and then it brings back all
these you know different memories and
and the things that I do remember one of
my uh greatest uh gifts I believe is uh
I'm able to recall things you know in
detail you know at a young age
and uh so
um and that kind of helped me you know
uh
uh um find myself and it kind of helped
me understand
how it is you know could happen because
I keep asking myself you know why me you
know you know you know why this happened
to me
and so of course yeah I believe I
believe it definitely had something to
do with it do you have children I have
no children I'm not sure no girlfriend
I've had a girlfriend and I don't know
how long you know I haven't had no sex
none of that since I've been out I
haven't had no sex really and
man it's been about
um you know
um she's been she's been it's been a
long time you know all together so my my
uh passion you know uh uh the course of
drugs
you know so that's pretty much my life
man that's my girlfriend I've been my
girlfriend trying to change all that now
but uh but that's how it's been for me
and um so
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently
um
I don't know well I probably would talk
to my mother you know some more and try
to you know get her to uh maybe share uh
you know some of the things he probably
went through and then if that would have
happened I think I'd have did better you
know because I would have realized you
know what it was she needed you know
from me or whatever you know in terms of
you know maybe helping out you know
instead of causing her so much trouble
and stuff like that you know
so I would change that and then I don't
know if I had a
if I had a capacity to change something
different you know than what happened
because I mean this is just something
that happened that I was coming up and
uh I believe I was powerless you even
changed any of that you know so that
part I would change though is to talk to
her more you know and uh tell her that I
love her and and try to do whatever I
can't assure that you know I love her
and I but I understand what it is he
went through you know in her life
because she didn't have a good life
herself she sacrificed all of that for
us and it still turns out bad in terms
of you know uh you know the separation
that we have today I have today with my
family with my siblings
yeah what's your biggest fear now
um you've been free for how long say
that again you've been out of prison for
how long I got out this time in November
and November 7th and so I've been out
for it's only been a few months now and
now I don't know I really don't I I
guess it probably you know success Maybe
you know uh because I I
never had no problem doing things like
you know because I'm pretty good at you
know I got marketable skills you know
that I developed while I was in there I
never had a problem working and stuff
like that there's always you know
hustled you know a little pain and
construction work gardening and stuff
like that and I stayed out of the
household and I guess that was a re that
was a way to get away too you know
because you know every time I would come
around I would get these you know uh you
know uh you know verbal abuse and uh
because I was you know bad but bad sheep
of the family and so that was a way for
me to um you know get out and kind of
like be on my own and not have to deal
with uh you know
the the problems you know or the family
or whatever was going on so pretty much
when I came in it was like sleep time or
something like that and I was doing all
over
yeah so I have skills in terms of work
and stuff like that and but it's never
been official I never had a job and uh
official job you've never had a real job
no I never had a job I've been in prison
over half my life like I said and so I
know I never had a job and um not
officially
but I always worked I mean you know I
work with my older brother too he likes
me because I go and help him out he
likes it how I work and so a lot of
times he would have me do things for him
while he go on his regular job and come
back and help me too he uh he's kind of
he was a
construct uh contractor
and my oldest brother and um so you know
I've developed some pretty good skills
you know stuff like that so that was
never no real problem for me
it's just a drug abuse that got me
Wayne what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
um the drugs that drug didn't know what
how drugs destroy you
you know because uh you know you're not
able to beat uh uh your appointments and
and you know because you're chasing the
drugs and and uh you know you would like
to do better but of course you know you
you have a habit or whatever and so you
you after that and then you look up and
time and got away from you and then the
people that's around you they [__] of
course they don't want no parts of it
either you know because uh they know
what it'll do or what have you and so
you lose up
um that too you know with with your
family or friends or whoever
and uh and and you really probably don't
get the assistance that you might need
or the love that you probably would need
to overcome the parliament you have so
um yeah I definitely would try to change
that
you know so I believe I come a long way
but that's many years it is Behind the
Walls you know reading a lot of books
and stuff like that you know that I kind
of like found myself I believe
you know and so that's where I'm at it's
a day
all right thank you so much for sharing
your story I appreciate it I wish you
lots of luck now that you're out I
appreciate you too I appreciate you uh
taking the time up I'll be your job yeah